Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's question Tuesday, the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters.
I asked for brief questions and of course
I got them, beginning: briefs or boxers?
I wear boxer briefs, lets move on!
"If everybody stopped sneezing, how long do
you think it would take somebody to realize
it?"
Wow, I don't know.
I guess I'm gonna say like a month, but I'd
like to see some rigorous research applied
to the question it's a very interesting one.
I think it would take a little while for people
to be like "hey, have you sneezed recently?
Because I haven't."
"How do you think having children has impacted
your writing?"
I guess there are a lot of times where 2009
me would have been writing and 2015 me is
making a Lego wookie gun ship.
But I gotta say I don't really feel like it's
a bad change, I mean this thing holds 2 different
Wookiees, it has double wookie pilots.
"A girl at my school told me she'd rather
be popular than smart, what's the correct
response to this?"
mmmm... sympathy?
"Hey John, what's your middle name?"
Danger!
It's not.
It's Michael.
"Last TV show you marathoned?"
The Americans, which is excellent.
"Hey, are you writing another book?"
You know another awesome thing about this
wookie gun ship it opens up, it's got like
a cargo bay inside of it.
"Who's a relatively unknown poet you love?"
There's a lot but the first who comes to mind
is the Persian poet Hafiz who I feel like
is not as well-known here as he should be.
"Apart from pizza, what do you think is the
best--" No, no, no, there is no "apart from
pizza."
Not a lot of things in this world that make
me angry, but you should not be apart from
pizza.
Alright, I apologize for the seriousness but
that's something I feel strongly about.
Let's return to lighter questions!
"Hey, I heard they're making Looking For Alaska
into a movie, who're you going to cast--"
I don't cast movie adaptations of my books
or actually any movies.
"Hey, will you cast Katie Ho--" Yeah, I just
don't cast movies.
I'm a novelist and a video blogger and a pizza
enthusiast, and not a caster of films.
"Hey, when are you gonna do your inkless tattoo
punishment?"
Soon.
Ish.
Maybe I should get "I don't cast movies" Tattoo'd
on my face.
No, that's a bad idea even for an inkless
tattoo but I do need a tattoo idea, let me
know if you have any in comments.
"If you could use one dinosaur to ride onto
it's back into battle, what dinosaur would
it be?"
Hey Henry?
I have a dino-question for you.
Apparently we're gonna go with Apatosaurus.
"Hey now that you're back home, what project
are you most excited to work on?"
Well, we still haven't put the wings on.
I think they like flap, it's gonna be awesome
when it's finished.
Also, I'm signing my name over and over again
so that independent bookstores around the
US will have signed copies of Paper Towns
for the holidays.
"Hey, I didn't see your cameo in the Paper
Towns movie."
Yeah it's not so much something you see so
much as it's someone you hear.
And finally, "Do you think you or Hank would
get further in American Ninja Warrior."
Henry and I have been watching a lot of American
Ninja Warrior, so I have a built-in advantage
because I at least know what it is, whereas
I suspect Hank doesn't.
I actually like my odds to get past the quintuple
steps.
So yeah, I'm gonna say me.
Hank, maybe we can add American Ninja Warrior
to next year's quadragicon.
In the meantime, I will see you on Friday.
Wait, I forgot to answer the most-asked question
of the week!
"Can we see Willie?"
Willie!
Treat!
Hi.
(gurgling/babbling noises)